hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast the persistence of pertussis
and the prognostic value of Bordetella
detection presented by dr. Carissa Cole
birth medical director infectious
disease Reiko reference laboratories and
associate professor department pathology
University of New Mexico School of
Medicine I am Xavier Gutierrez of lab
routes and I will be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab routes and sponsored by
dias Oren molecular for more information
about our sponsor visit
www.meliar.com/mpanel.htm the screen our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email if you have trouble seeing or
hearing me the presentation please click
on the ask a question box to let us know
that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
those offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Cobra I will now turn the presentation
over to her hello I'm Carissa culbreth
and I'm here today to speak with you
about the persistence of pertussis and
the prognostic value of Bordetella
detection and just a little bit about
the laboratory where I work we are
trying for reference laboratories
located in Albuquerque New Mexico we are
a regional hospital laboratory a
regional reference laboratory and we
provide laboratory services for three
major health systems in New Mexico in
addition to the hospitals that we serve
we also provide laboratory testing for
commercial physician and other smaller
Community Hospital clients throughout
the state as a frame of reference for
infectious disease laboratory our volume
is about 850,000 to 900 thousand tests
performed in the laboratory each year
and this ranges from the basic
laboratory tests such as cultures to
more esoteric molecular testing all of
the samples that are received in our
laboratory are delivered by a courier
and we have courier services going
throughout this state and bringing
specimens to the laboratory 24/7 and we
are running tests in the laboratory 24/7
so here today we are speaking about
Bordetella pertussis and other members
of the board at Ellis species group
regarding Bordetella pertussis humans
are the only host for Bordetella
pertussis which is transmitted by
droplet transmission Bordetella pertains
several virulence factors of these the
most important causing disease is Bor
the pertussis toxin
however there's other toxins and
virulence factors that play a role in
disease pathogenesis including tracheal
cytotoxin which destroys the ciliated
cells and inhibits cell regeneration
adenylate cyclase hemolysis which
induces a pitocin sub cells
the filament filament is human
hemoglobin promotes binding to various
cell types and the thin barrier that
helps to support colonization of the
entire respiratory tract these virulence
factors taken together together with
pertussis toxin are what are able to
mediate the pathogenesis of the organism
in the human host there are multiple
stages of pertussis infection that we
are able to see in in disease the first
stage is the catarrhal stage this is the
early stage that's occurring during this
initial incubation period of seven to
ten days of incubation at this point
what we would see clinically are
nonspecific symptoms
mimicking influenza-like illness these
would consist of a low-grade fever sore
throat nasal congestion congestion and
other influenza-like illness symptoms
these symptoms are generally mild but
there is a progressive dry cough that
will later become more indicative and
classic in the presentation of pertussis
the next stage that we would see is the
paroxysmal stage this stage is when we
would see the classic whooping cough
which gives pertussis it's a most
commonly known name of whooping cough
we also would see post tests and
vomiting a profuse production of mucus
would occur at this stage and in the
paroxysms following coughing they would
occur at night and they increase in
frequency throughout the next two to
three weeks of infection the last stage
that we would see with pertussis is the
convalescent stage and at this stage the
disease severity begins to wane the
paroxysms decrease in frequency duration
and severity but there remains a mild
cough and this cough can last up to six
weeks during the course of the stages of
infection we see the organism burden be
the highest during the catarrhal stage
and then it will decrease over time
through the convalescent stage and
during this time is when we're really
seeing the the activity of these
virulence factors in particular the
pertussis toxin when it comes to
pathogenesis so a little bit more
specifically about pertussis toxin this
toxin is only expressed in Bordetella
pertussis and the toxin itself is an a/b
toxin the toxin is released from
Bordetella pertussis in an inactive form
and then it binds the cell membrane
receptor and is taken up into the
endosome and it travels through the
endoplasmic reticulum the alpha subunit
itself acts as the promoter and then
once it becomes activated it prevents
the activity of the g-protein coupled
receptors and
interferes with intracellular
communication and increases studies in a
concentration of cyclic a and P and it
disrupts the cellular function through
its adp ribosylation activity there are
other Bordetella species that can cause
disease other than Bordetella pertussis
these species include Bordetella para
pertussis bronco sceptic and home CA all
of these can produce disease but they're
all have more mild presentations in
general than Bordetella pertussis
Bordetella pertussis lacks the
production of the toxin due to a
mutation in the promoter region it can
cause a pertussis like illness but as I
stated before this illness is more mild
and presentation in general than with
Bordetella pertussis there are two hosts
for Bordetella pertussis humans and
sheep Bordetella bronchus etiqa also
lacks production of the bordetella
pertussis toxin it can cause mild
respiratory illness but not necessarily
pertussis like illness and you may not
see as long of a duration of coughing
who won't see any of the paroxysms or
the pertussis post-tests vomiting that
she would see with Bordetella pertussis
and then there are also multiple host
humans as well as other animal hosts
Bordetella home ci is an interesting and
emerging pathogen that we that we are
beginning to see as we're expanding our
diagnostic capabilities for Bordetella
species it cause and causes a mild
respiratory illness in immunocompetent
host but we'll speak a little bit
further about the illnesses that it may
be able to cause and we're starting to
see a bit more of an immunocompromised
hosts and again as with Bordetella
pertussis the only known host for
Bordetella home CI are humans as hosts
so when we look at
the clinical presentation though of
Bordetella pertussis compared to
Bordetella pertussis we can see that
there are some significant differences
but there are some overlaps when it
comes to the clinical presentation of
these two pathogens what we do see for
Bordetella pair processes is that there
tends to be a shortened cough duration
compared to Bordetella pertussis
Bordetella pertussis has an average of
14 days the median of coughs compared to
28 day average cough duration for
Bordetella pertussis the presentation of
the symptoms though of the pertussis
like symptoms actually tend to be fairly
similar although we don't see as much of
the paroxysmal cough or the post tested
vomiting the wolf can be present in
Bordetella pertussis apnea is present
with the less common frequency however
there are some sleep disturbances fewer
hospitalizations and then fewer deaths
are also seen with parapet esses and
what we do see though is that many of
the patients who would have a bit more
to tell a parent processes are up to
date with their vaccinations for
pertussis and that's because there's no
protection no crossing protection
between Bordetella pertussis and para
pertussis when it comes to vaccinations
for Bordetella pertussis when it comes
to the presentation for Bordetella home
CI what we do see is that in
immunocompetent patients there is mostly
just a mild upper respiratory illness
but we're seeing some emerging
challenges and infections in
immunocompromised hosts in the
immunocompromised hosts infants we're
seeing pertussis Lite illness however
it's a more mild presentation with fewer
of the classic pertussis symptoms that
are seen they're shorter Coster
raishin in overall there's a more mild
respiratory illness when it comes to the
respiratory presentation of infection
however what we are seeing is that there
is more commonly occurring with
Bordetella home ci than we see with
Bordetella pertussis a systemic
infection in these infections in
immunocompromised hosts and we see as
bacteremia cellulitis and pneumonia and
this we very rarely if ever would see it
with Bordetella pertussis in
immunocompetent or infant hosts so we're
seeing Bordetella home CI as certainly
an emerging and interesting infection
that may warn some additional attention
in the future as we're seeing increased
numbers of immunocompromised patients of
course in our population however
bringing it back to Bordetella pertussis
we are seeing in the community that
there is a resurgence of Bordetella
pertussis following major vaccination
strategies over the past 50 years and
and there's two major factors that are
the cause of this resurgence of
Bordetella pertussis one of the factors
is waning immunity and so we've
initially with the Tdap acellular
vaccine that had the pertussis toxin and
various pertussis factors that were
included in the vaccine the immunity is
expected to last initially about 30
years but what research is now showing
when we look at the zero status of
individuals is that the immunity is
really lasting more in the range of 40
to 20 years with demonstrated vaccine
effectiveness in the younger age groups
of eight to twelve year olds twenty to
forty percent so there's limited vaccine
effectiveness and in combination with a
shortened immunity immunity period we're
seeing that we
and this issue of waning immunity what
also has been shown in animal models is
that the initial acellular vaccine did
not have a reduction in the nasal
carriage of the organism so there may
have been additional transmission
opportunities while an individual may
not get the disease themselves without
the reduction in the nasal carriage of
the organism you would potentially still
be able to transmit the infection to
other naive hosts and so these factors
together have impacted the immunity
that's been achieved with the vaccine
however in addition to those kin factors
addressed with immunity what we've also
seen is that there are molecular
adaptations in the organism itself that
are impacting the ability of pertussis
to research in the population so we're
seeing molecular annotations in the
pertussis toxin in protectin and in the
thehm brigade that have been targets for
the vaccine and so that may allow those
allelic variations to emerge in
population there's also been emergence
of protecting deficient strains and this
emergence began around 1994 worldwide in
fact in 2012 the CDC survey the isolates
that it had in its database and found
that over 50% of the isolates tested by
the CDC were in fact protect and
deficient and this appears to be at
least associated somewhat with this
resurgence of Bordetella pertussis but
in combination with these things we're
also finding and I think it's important
to recognize that around this time of
recognition of waning immunity and
emergence of molecular adaptations we
also have improved diagnostic methods
which is also helping us to detect more
cases of pertussis and perhaps this is
also playing a factor in the resurgence
of pertussis in the canoe
so when we think about the diagnostic
methods that we've had available to us
over time we find that there have been
some challenges with diagnosis of
pertussis culture for Bordetella
pertussis is only about 60 percent
sensitive and the highest recovery rate
for culture is with infants when the
specimens are collected within the first
two weeks of the COFF the challenge with
this is that within those first two
weeks of the call they can this can
still be within this initial catarrhal
phase where one may not have pertussis
high on the differential because you
haven't had that extended coughed period
and it may just be perceived as an
influenza-like illness however having
cultures for Bordetella pertussis is
important because it is useful to detect
these mutations that can help us to
understand how the vaccine is impacting
the the organism and allelic variants
that may be emerging and we can also use
these isolates to detect emerging
antimicrobial resistance the CDC in fact
has initiated some initiatives to
recover more broader teleport OSIS
isolates to combat these various factors
also there are specific media that are
required for the detection of and in
recovery of Bordetella pertussis in the
laboratory and most laboratories don't
routinely keep these media on in stock
in the laboratory the organism is quite
fastidious and can take many days a week
or more for recovery on these specific
media so culture is just not a routine
method that is done in the laboratory
though there are certainly some benefits
for having culture available okay so as
we examine the options for diagnostic in
the optimal timing for diagnostic
testing for pertussis we see that from
the time of cough onset culture is the
is optimal only in those first two weeks
after that and that's when pertussis
really becomes more on the differential
for for clinicians once patients have
past that initial cat oral phase where
the patient would have influenza like
illness and perhaps a more mild cough
after that second week is when the
patient would begin to enter into some
of the more classic pertussis symptoms
and that is when other methods become
more available and are optimal for the
diagnosis of pertussis including
utilization of PCR and molecular testing
as well as serological testing so we'll
look first at the use of serologic
testing for pertussis while it's not
often used because it can be challenging
and that it can require acute and
convalescent specimens the detection of
the specific anti pertussis toxin
antibodies can be helpful and can be
used as a sensitive way to establish
infections whence when a significant
duration of time has passed and
relatively late in disease but there are
many factors that do impact the accuracy
and the sensitivity of cerró diagnosis
of pertussis this can include the time
elapsed since the last vaccination or if
there was a previous infection and
whether or not only the primary series
of a vaccination has occurred or booster
vaccinations were given in addition the
overall antigen content of the vaccine
and the age of the patient are all
factors that have to be weighed in when
determining the the clinical
significance of the positive result and
so this is really a challenge when it
comes to utilization of serologic
testing and interpreting the result
serology can't be used during the year
following vac
and with all of these factors there's
really some challenges and in some cases
limited diagnostic value for deciding
treatment or prophylactic decisions for
Bordetella pertussis so this brings us
to the utilization of molecular testing
and molecular diagnostics for pertussis
when we're looking at this method
overall we utilized insertion sequence
elements as the primary target for
Bordetella nat assays we utilize at
least three of these insertion sequences
to try to help us to differentiate
between multiple species of pertussis
and our Bordetella and then other
factors can be used for further
speciation so looking first at the
insertion sequence for a t1 it is
present in Bordetella pertussis and
anywhere from 50 to 200 copies so this
makes it a wonderful target for the
detection of Bordetella pertussis
because it's president so many copies we
can get to a higher sensitivity in
detection of Bordetella pertussis in
clinical specimens however there is a
challenge in that it can be present in
Bordetella homes the eye at a lower copy
number of 10 to 50 copies so this does
bring up some challenges because any
specimen that is positive for insertion
sequence 41 could also potentially be
not just Bordetella pertussis it could
actually also be Bordetella homes yet
additionally fewer very few only 3% but
certainly it's present in 3% of
Bordetella Branko septic a' cluster1
strains but the insertion sequence 481
provides us with a good potential for
use for the detection of Bordetella
pertussis then we have the insertion
sequence 1001 which is present
and Bordetella pertussis add a copy
number of 22 but it is also present in
29% of Bordetella Park Aesthetica
cluster one strains and a variant of
this insertion sequence can also be
detected in Bordetella home CI at about
three to five copies the insertion
sequence 1002 is present in Bordetella
pertussis at a very low copy number less
than ten copies and also seen at less
than ten copies for Bordetella pair
processes and only in one copy for
Bordetella Branca septic ax so this is
traditionally not used as a detection
method for Bordetella species
additionally to help to increase the
specificity for Bordetella pertussis the
pertussis toxin which is only present in
Bordetella pertussis can be used to
improve the specificity for molecular
targets however it is only present in
one copy so we run into some sensitivity
challenges and then rec a can be used to
help to differentiate those the
detection of word it's on the whole TI
as it is present in only one copy for
Bordetella home CI and only present in
Bordetella homes yet so we see these
multi copy genes and they're certainly
helpful to support diagnostic
sensitivity which is needed when it
comes to the detection of Bordetella
pertussis and this use of multi copy
genes is helpful because we can then
detect sensitivities less than or at one
CFU however this does present a
challenge because it could even detect
colonization or carrier states using the
insertion SICU sequence 141 though we do
run into specificity risk because this
insertion sequence is present
Berta teleport Estes and in Bordetella
home CI
so how do we mitigate this specificity
risk of the insertion sequence one of
the things that could be done is through
review of additional sequences such as
the insertion sequence one thousand one
or two to differentiate between
Bordetella pertussis home CI in para
pertussis but to differentiate between
the presence of Bordetella pertussis and
Bordetella home CI one could do periodic
surveillance aboard a cell of home CI in
your population to determine whether or
not born Estella's home zi is ever
circulating in the population or you can
add a second target for increased
sensitivity such as the addition of the
pertussis toxin or wreck a to
differentiate between Bordetella
pertussis and Bordetella home CI so this
could be you know a potential model to
look at how would one determine whether
or not you have Bordetella pertussis or
Bordetella home CI circulating within
the population by the addition of
Bordetella pertussis toxin detection and
Rec a to increase the specificity for
Bordetella pertussis and Bordetella home
CI however we do risk at this point with
the one copy gene sensitivity at low
organism burdens that we often see in
diagnostic specimens so an additional
method that one could use instead of the
addition of the pertussis toxin or
Recces would be the addition of the
insertion sequence 1002 to increase the
specificity for differentiation of
Bordetella pertussis imported cell at
home CI because it is present in a
higher copy number then produces toxin
and Recces however both of these present
still the challenge of sensitivity
and the potential loss of sensitivity
while increasing specificity so overall
it's still I think becomes the best
method to focus on the insertion
sequence 1 1 481 for detection of
Bordetella pertussis recognizing that
there may be some carryover cross
reactivity to Bordetella home CI and
doing periodic surveillance in the
population to determine whether or not
Bordetella home CI is present in the
community in our laboratory we use a
laboratory developed tests identifying
the primer pair that targets the
insertion sequence for T 1 which would
detect Bordetella pertussis as well as
some potential carryover cross
reactivity to Bordetella home CA we also
have this multiplex with the detection
of Bordetella pair of pertussis using
the insertion sequence 1001 this also
includes an internal control primer pair
that is used to monitor PCR
amplification and or inhibition and the
assay is performed on the liaison mdx
instrument we have evaluated in our
laboratory two methods for detection of
pertussis and pair pertussis in
specimens in the laboratory we use one
method and evaluated one method which is
an extraction method where we extract
200 microliters of vtm from a
nasopharyngeal specimen or nasal wash
that is received in the laboratory and
then we utilize 5 microliters of the
extracted nucleic acid in the master mix
for detection of the specimen we then
were able to compare this method to a
direct detection method where we take
the needs of pharyngeal swab that's in
VTN and we utilize 3 microliters of that
direct specimen of the vtm and add that
to the master mix in both of these cases
the samples were tested with the D S on
the essaouira and molecular primer
on the LIA liaison mdx instrument using
the 96-well universal disks it's
important to note that these assays are
laboratory-developed tests and this was
used with ASR reagents and it's not
cleared by the FDA when we evaluated the
performance of the direct versus the
extracted method we used 147 previously
characterized specimens and they were
detected they were tested by both
methods we evaluated for the presence of
pertussis and parent pertussis among
these specimens and we find that there
was a positive agreement of 92.9% and a
negative agreement of 100% focusing on
the seven specimens that were positive
by the extracted method but were
detected by the direct method we
evaluated these discrepant results and
we've looked at these results based on
the CT range of the specimens so what we
can see is that when specimens were in
the CT range of having a psycho
threshold between 10 and 20 there was
100% agreement and we see that same 100
percent agreement when we have a psycho
threshold of 21 to 30 however at the
later cycle thresholds of greater than
31 is where we began to see the
emergence of the discrepant samples at
31 to 35 however there were agreement
with 20 of the specimens and only four
discrepant samples at 35 plus we had
four samples that are agreed and there
were four samples that were discrepant
and then when we look at the type of
samples
among these discrepant we see that we
had four Bordetella pertussis and para
pertussis at the 31 to 35 there were 30
sorry to Bordetella pertussis samples
that didn't agree and one Bordetella
pertussis sample that didn't agree the
third the fourth
among those 31 to 35 was an
indeterminate sample that we weren't
able to do further discrepant analysis
on for the 35 plus cycle threshold value
we found three Bordetella pertussis
samples that were discrepant m1
Bordetella pair princesses sample that
was described it you can see for all of
these that these have very fairly late
CT values in the in the specimens so
when we evaluate the analytic detection
of pertussis we determine the
sensitivity of this these two real-time
PCR assays by measuring tenfold serial
dilutions of purified pertussis and pair
of pertussis nucleic acid we evaluated
these at 10 to the 0 and 10 to the 7
genomic equivalents per reaction and
then we determine the average CT value
based on the five replicates that
weren't evaluated at each of the
concentrations for each of the target
performance and what we were able to
determine is that for the extracted
method we have earlier CT values
compared to the direct method they are
slightly later and then we as we go down
into increasing lead diluted specimens
we find that by the time that we get to
10 to the 0 genomic equivalents we're no
longer able to accurately detect a
prototype error pertussis in the
specimen for the direct extraction we
are able to still direct detect
Bordetella pertussis but at a fairly
late CT value and so this does
correspond with the data that we saw
with our discrepant results that we
start to get later crossing thresholds
and potentially begin to miss the
detection of Bordetella pertussis and
pair of processes once we get into the
lower concentrations of organisms
present in the sample
as determined by this sensitivity study
so then when we compare the CT values
for Bordetella pertussis and para
processes for linearity in the extracted
vs. and non extracted or direct
specimens we see that when we view our y
intercept we do have a bias towards a
later CT value for the non extracted
specimens however there is still a
fairly good correlation of these seats u
values at point nine five for the for
the the r-squared and the slope is that
one but there is somewhat of a bias
towards later CT value as we can see for
the y intercept so what would be some of
these causes as we look at the direct
versus extracted values for pertussis
what would cause a late CT and basically
a lower organism burden in the specimen
the timing from the specimen collection
post symptom development would result in
fewer organisms present and a lower
organism ad would as with the timing
from specimen collection following
antibiotic treatment it's been
demonstrated that patients with older
age have a lower organism burden and if
there's environmental contamination with
pertussis that would also potential
contamination sources though there would
be a false positive they're usually
present at a lower organism burden so
all of these would have an impact on the
CT value and for the specimens and an
overall the organism burden that we
would see in these specimens so I'm
gonna shift gears just a little bit
because we really need to kind of focus
on what are we looking for when we're
looking to detect pertussis in the
clinical specimen we can evaluate the
analytical sensitivity of the test but
it's also important to understand
clinically what are the
specimens that we are receiving in the
laboratory because all of the factors
that I mentioned previously would all be
influenced by these pre-analytical
forces that would impact the specimen
that we received in the lab so just a
bit about New Mexico pertussis
Epidemiology New Mexico has experienced
protested rates of epidemic proportions
of pertussis since 2011 in 2012 New
Mexico actually experienced a three-fold
increase in cases compared to 2011 and
the US even during that time also
experienced the highest incidence of
pertussis since 1959 but historically
New Mexico itself has had higher
pertussis rates than have been seen
overall in the United States when it
comes to the overall vaccination
recommendations infants and children are
expected to receive five doses of Tdap
at two four six and then 15 to 18 months
and then once at a point between four to
six years of age
adolescents then receive a single dose
of Tdap at eleven to twelve years of age
and then pregnant women are expected to
receive a single dose of Tdap during
every pregnancy at 12 to 36 weeks of
gestation so when we look more
specifically at the New Mexico pertussis
epidemiology and think about these
vaccination recommendations we see that
the highest age group that most commonly
has Bordetella pertussis especially
during these outbreak years 2011 - in
about 2013 were children ages less than
one so children in the infant age range
were certainly an outlier patients ages
at greater than 20 remained fairly low
during this time period but there is a
slight bump during that outbreak set of
years
and then the patients and the remainder
of the age ranges appeared to just
clustered together in the rates of
pertussis per 100,000 population so when
we look more specifically at the sources
of infant transmission we see that
mothers at the age of zero to one month
of age are the most common cause of
pertussis transmission which is the
cause and the need for mothers to get a
vaccination during every pregnancy
however it's important to note that
siblings are the most common source of
infant transmission for any age from the
0 to 1 month of age or the 2 to 11 month
of age so it is certainly important to
recognize siblings as a source of
pertussis transmission for the infants
in the population so when we consider
our pertussis cases and our immunization
rates in New Mexico what we see is that
there really isn't a strong correlation
between the numbers of pertussis cases
and whether or not individuals are
immunized for pertussis we can see that
the areas with the highest pertussis
cases in the slide and the image on the
left are in the darker shading and the
places with the highest rates of
vaccination on the right side are in the
darkish sorry are in the lighter shading
so the places where people are most
fully immunized on the right side are
the lighter shading so we can see that
there's really not a huge correlation
that the the places that have the
highest cases of pertussis are not
necessarily in places that have the
lowest rates of immunization so this
shows us that we are in some ways
fighting this uphill battle of effects
of immunity and waning immunity immunity
and perhaps it
virgins of other strains of pertussis as
well as trying to control the number of
cases but this is also why surveillance
for pertussis is extremely important so
when it comes to Department of Health
needs we in New Mexico utilize and
enhance pertussis surveillance because
of the epidemic that we have been in
over the past several years and so we
see the clinical case definition for
pertussis that in the absence of a more
likely diagnosis a cough illness lasting
greater than equal to two weeks with one
of the pertussis symptoms being the
clinical case definition and then a
confirmed case is an acute cost cough
with the isolation of Bordetella
pertussis from a clinical specimen or a
PCR positive or a contact with a case
that has had contact with a laboratory
confirmed case of pertussis and so what
we did in our laboratory was we entered
into a partnership in collaboration with
the New Mexico Department of Health
enhanced pertussis surveillance we
evaluated specimens with the Department
of Health from 2013 to 2015 we evaluate
evaluated 418 pertussis positive
patients by PCR that also had a
concurrent Department of Health
investigation results from this
investigation were aligned with PCR CT
values and we correlated these results
with the results of the Department of
Health investigation there were some
limitations to this study one pertussis
negative specimens and patients were not
included in the study and we did not
have enough Bordetella pair of pertussis
positives patients that also had an
investigation for significance and so
they were not included in the study and
in the evaluation so we look at the
demographics of the patients who were
included in this study to look at kind
of the political factors that come into
play with pertussis diagnosis
we see that there was a fairly even
distribution between a male and female
the age tended to be the mean age was 14
years of age when we look at the
clinical data we find that patients had
an average of 23 days of cough duration
with a variety of presentation for the
other pertussis like the pertussis
symptoms that would fall within the case
definition and the most commonly
occurring symptoms is the paroxysmal
caught but also present was post-test
vomiting whoop apnea cyanosis we did not
have any cases of acute encephalopathy
or any deaths but there were 35 or
around 8% of the patients were
hospitalized there was only one case of
a gent of sorry four cases of a patient
with generalized focal seizure
interestingly in only 72% of the cases
were antibiotics given and then 61
percent of the cases had ever received a
vaccine 11 percent of the cases were
outbreak associated when we look at the
demographic profile of the patients to
determine the percent of the population
that met the criteria of a case clinical
case definition for pertussis we find
that across the age range around 80
percent or a bit over 80% of the
population met the clinical criteria of
the presence of the paroxysms of
coughing or the other factors for
pertussis case definition now when we
look at the CT value of the percent of
the patients who met the pertussis
diagnostic criteria we find that the
highest percentage of patients who meet
the pertussis criteria had less than 30
CT value so had a higher organism burden
so in the the patients who had this
higher organism burden and nine
percent of the those patients met the
clinical criteria excluding the
diagnosis of pertussis from that
criteria and only looking at the
clinical factors 90% of the patients
with the CT value of less than 30 met
these case definition when you had the
population of patients between 30 and 40
approximately eighty-five percent of the
special patients had the clinical
symptoms associated with pertussis and
then of the patients who had greater
than 40 CT value this was a much lower
number but 70 percent of those patients
had the clinical factors that would be
associated with pertussis now one of the
things that we were able to do with our
population is look at the impact of the
symptoms and the demographic factors on
the CT value so what we did was we
developed a reference patient that had
kind of basic demographics so we said
this patient it would be kind of our
model patient that we would then compare
every other demographic value against
this patient a gender had no impact on
the the CT value as we saw earlier so we
just arbitrarily selected the patient to
be female we selected this kind of
reference patient to be an adult 18 to
64 years old that they were
hypothetically tested the day after
immediately after symptoms started that
they had never received antibiotics and
that we selected a fairly median CT
value of 30 and so when we look at them
the relative contribution of each of the
demographic factors and then a couple of
the more significant clinical symptoms
what we see is that again
gender had no impact on the CT value
whether or not it would increase or
decrease above or below 30 but what we
do see is that in patients who are less
than one year old that significantly
drops the CT value by six point five
four points
the other ages with the exception of
greater than 64 years of old of age
which also dropped the CT value by about
33 points sorry about three points the
remainder of the ages really did not
have an impact on the overall CT value
when we look at the clinical
presentation and the cough onset to
testing per day what we see is an
increase in the CT value as we add each
day of cough before testing occurs so
for instance if testing was occurred the
day after the cough occurred there would
be no impact and then on day two there
would it be an increase of 0.12 on the
sense that on the CT value and a factor
of 0.12 increase on each subsequent day
of testing and so this shows that the CT
value increases as the conservation
continues if patients received
antibiotics prior to testing that would
add about two and a half to our CT value
and so we can look at these factors and
determine how the clinical factors
associated with the disease and the
demographic factors for the patient
would play a role on whether or not we
would be able to detect pertussis in a
clinical specimen again if we look at
this data by age we can look at the
relative response to CT value and the
symptoms by age and what we find again
is that in the patients that are less
than one adding any of these clinical
symptoms would increase our sorry
decrease the CT value because there
would be overall higher burden but in
the older patients we see that the CT
value tends to go up a bit more because
lightly the patients are able to control
a little bit better the infection that
they may be seeing in the patient and
the
clinical specimen we may have left less
as the specimen less of the organism
present in the specimen so finally in
conclusion what we see is that the
changing academia epidemiology of
Bordetella pertussis really highlights
the need for effective and rapid
molecular diagnostic testing we
certainly in New Mexico have seen an
outbreak of Bordetella pertussis
multiple outbreaks in multiple settings
and we continue to have relative high
pertussis rates here in New Mexico so
molecular testing that provides
sensitive and rapid molecular
diagnostics is certainly important in
our laboratory we've used the do Soren
molecular Bordetella pertussis and para
pertussis reagents and these can be used
to detect Bordetella pertussis and para
pertussis with or without extraction we
find that lower CT values are positively
correlated with a patient's likelihood
of meeting pertussis case definitions
and symptom presentations and then
finally demographic and clinical
profiles seem to have predictable
effects on the CT value and this can
help us to understand a bit more about
how sensitivity of certain tests and
even the results in the lab can
translate into a clinical response so
thank you very much for your time and
I'm happy to take any questions from the
viewers of this presentation thank you
thank you dr. Cole Ruth for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email okay let's get
started
our first question is are there
Bordetella pertussis carriers who do not
have symptoms but can spread to
unvaccinated
definitely I think as I was able to show
in one of the slides earlier the
transmission to infants many of those
individuals as siblings parents
grandparents others can certainly be
asymptomatic or they may just have some
of them a more mild presentation of
disease because they may be partially
vaccinated and so they can be carriers
and so certainly they can transmit
Bordetella pertussis to under
unvaccinated individuals and the most at
risk for severe disease and in the
unvaccinated population is most
certainly infants so it is certainly
important for vaccination to occur and
people who would potentially have
contact with unvaccinated individuals
especially infants and how do you tell
the difference between an active
infection or carrier when the CT value
of the SAR the CT values of the assay
are high above a CTF thirty and do you
have a cut-off that is one of my studies
correlated with clinical context so I
think the the question being do we have
a a cut-off value that would distinguish
between a carrier state or active
disease you know that's really the
challenge is that a later CT value
doesn't necessarily mean that a patient
doesn't have active disease it could
still just be late in infection we're
talking about weeks of coughs when it
comes to the cat oral phase and then
even the convalescent stage and then by
the time an individual presents with
pertussis
they're usually presenting several weeks
after the cough has initiated I believe
our data showed the coffee average cough
duration at the time of testing was 14
days so that's two weeks after the
initial
initial presentation of the cough so
there's this challenge with pertussis
diagnosis do you have a cut-off where
you decide that you're going to either
no longer report or report some type of
equivocal range where you say a patient
may not have active disease I think
that's that's a challenge I think really
it's it's important to understand the
factors that impact a later CT value and
to work in collaboration with clinicians
and Public Health to help them
understand that a patient who has been
coughing for a long duration or a
patient who may have been treated at
some point would certainly have a
positive result but it may be leader I
think it's important to help clinicians
understand the mechanisms behind the
testing but we in our laboratory do not
have a cut-off after 30 or after 35 if
we have a positive result in our test a
result of as positive but and we do not
utilize a cut-off because I think
there's just some clinical challenges
that make having a cut-off value even
more difficult to interpret and how
often are you monitor monitoring or the
presence of Bordetella homeys in your
population and what is the prevalence
rate yeah so great thank you for
bringing that up I meant to mention that
in the presentation among the specimens
that we tested for the comparison
between the direct and the extracted
method we also checked for Bordetella
home ci we actually didn't find any in
our population so of just that about 147
I believe specimens so we routinely
we've done a couple of times over the
past two years has just done a couple of
point prevalence studies where we'll
take about 50 previously positive for
develop pertussis specimens and run them
to determine whether or not we have any
Bordetella home ci we haven't seen any
in our population but again it's not a
full surveillance study
that's a I think a great opportunity for
continued collaborations with
laboratories and their local departments
of health that's to determine whether or
not they have going to tell the poem's
the eyes circulating in populations and
how the lab could help to support
diagnosis and differentiation Bordetella
pertussis importance on the home ci all
right then we have time for one more
question in the last few months
what is the recent prevalence rate of
Bordetella pertussis in New Mexico so we
unfortunately are still seeing fairly
highly high rates of Bordetella
pertussis though they're starting to to
go back down right now I believe the the
last data that we were seeing was around
the five five cases per hundred thousand
and so we're hoping that we can continue
to see some decreases in those rates in
our population all right well I would
like to once again thank dr. Cobra for
her presentation I would also like to
thank dia sword for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December of
2018 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay be sure
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon